I believe I suppose in what could be
called democratic socialism that I
believe that we need a society where the
motive for the economic system is not
corporate profit but the motive is the
welfare of people the healthcare and
jobs and childcare and so on with that
that is dominant where there's a greater
equalization of wealth and a society
which is peaceful which devotes its
resources to helping people in the
country and elsewhere and and I believe
in a world where war is no longer the
recourse for the settling of grievances
and problems I believe in the wiping out
of national boundaries and I don't
believe in visas and passports and
immigration quotas I think we need to
move towards a global society they use
the word globalization but they use it
in a very narrow sense to mean the
freedom of corporations to move across
boundaries but what we need is the
freedom of people and things to move
across boundaries so am i if you when I
talk about socialism in our jails I mean
yes greater societal intervention into
the economy but without deprivation of
civil liberties Dalton Trumbo the
Hollywood writer put it very simply he
said yeah he said socialism without
jails
like to think of taking the best
elements of all of them and I'm
communism if if you separate communism
from the Soviet Union and from those
bureaucratic and totalitarian countries
that call themselves Marxist economist
and just treat communism as it was
envisioned by by Marx and Engels is
ultimately a society where there'll be a
freedom of the individual and a rational
use of the world's resources well that's
something to take from communism from
socialism I would take what I just
described and that is the use of the
government of a democratically elected
government to equalize resources and
help people I would take from anarchism
the suspicion of authority the suspicion
of all governments and the readiness to
criticize and rebel against any
government that may have started out in
a humanitarian way but they can easily
become ossified and dictatorial so
anarchism has as its goal the idea of a
kind of decentralized society where
individuals are free from the oppression
of government and corporate power and
the church so I think there are elements
in all three that are useful
well certainly not practical in the
sense of something that's immediately
achievable but it's it's I think very
important the whole is a goal
philosophical but not in a utopian sense
it makes it simply theoretical and and
unworkable philosophical only in the
sense that its long-term so although
it's not an immediate possibility or
probability I think it's very important
all to have an idea of what a good
society would be like so that you can
measure what is happening today and what
the policies are today against that goal
you